so Andrew Mitchell has said that the
evacuation process from Sudan is going
smoothly do you think it is
well I sincerely hope that it is we've
got this 72 hour window at the moment
with the ceasefire we really have to
have as a priority evacuating British
Nationals I understand now that an
evacuation Center has been set up we
have to do everything now that we
possibly can to make sure that all those
British Nationals come home and we make
that process as easy for them as
possible but then more widely we also
have to continue to push through
diplomatic channels to try to find and
end this Dreadful conflict
do you think the government should open
up more routes for people to claim
Asylum from countries like Sudan
well I think first of all with Sudan
we've got to work internationally to
look at neighboring countries because
clearly what we want to see is a
situation where the conflict is brought
to a conclusion and people can return to
their homes I think that has to be the
priority first of all
clearly there will be as well Sudanese
people here in the United Kingdom and
the government has to look at the
situation there may well be ongoing Visa
applications for example in terms of
family modes and the government really
does need to be looking at that as well
but the real priority has to be
internationally at this time
obviously we'd love to see a diplomatic
solution in Sudan right I think that
goes without saying
but you know realistically how much of a
role can the UK actually play in that
well we can actually do something is
take Asylum Seekers should we be doing
that
well firstly the UK still has quite
remarkable diplomatic clouds around the
world and that is something that I've
seen at firsthand the question is should
we be taking more Asylum Seekers from
Sudan well in terms of uh in terms of
that just to take that firstly I think
it has to be internationally first of
all that we do this it has to be an
international
solution where of course we should be
playing a part in that there is a wider
question too about resettlement schemes
we've run resettlement schemes
previously as to how they're working of
course we can look at that but the
priority at the moment has to be
internationally okay
um
obviously the Sudan situation is
happening at a time when you have also
been voting on the illegal migration
Bill and it does feel like these two
issues overlap we're talking about
people in need for Moses overseas should
we be taking in more Asylum Seekers
well I think we need to first of all
deal with the issue that we've got of
thousands of people who are risking
their lives in small boats in the
English Channel now I've been down to
Dover I've been in the past across to
France and seen it firsthand how
dangerous those sea lanes are now to
deal with this situation we need to do
in my view a number of things we
shouldn't be spending the money that's
being spent on the Rwanda scheme which
just a headline grabbing scheme we
should be using that money to set up a
specific sale in the National Crime
agency to try to deal with people
trafficking secondly we need to deal
with the Asylum backlog the Asylum
backlog is in the region about 138
000 the government just isn't dealing
with it I mean I've just voted in the
House of Commons for Fast Track
procedures in specific cases and the
government has just voted it down the
Asylum systems in Kirsten thirdly we we
then need much better return agreements
the government hasn't negotiated a
successor scheme to what was called the
Dublin 3 regulation the Dublin three
regulation both allowed us to return
people whose claims had failed to other
safe countries and also did include a
safe route that's what the government
now needs to do
so I've been listening like really
carefully to what you've been saying and
it really does strike me that labor talk
a lot about
attacking the government when it comes
to competence so getting rid of the
backlog of claims which don't get me
wrong I can see why that's something
that people feel they should be doing
like it's hard to disagree with that but
I guess what I'm trying to get to is
what labor undercused armor believes
when it comes to Asylum Seekers do you
believe that the UK should be taking
more Asylum Seekers well it will vary
once it year on year and what happens
here is people who come here and seek
Asylum what they actually should have is
a process that works very quickly for
each decided where they've got a value
but that is a matter for the courts I I
can't sit in either in any other
politician and tell you in a particular
year how many Asylum seeks have valid
claims and who don't that doesn't matter
for the court sure of course I would
never ask you to say which particular
people have valid claims or not but I
just think that there is an overall
question about what labor believes when
it comes to Asylum Seekers do you think
that we're taking enough Asylum Seekers
and I do think that some politicians
would be able to give you an answer to
that well the number that we take will
depend upon the number of valid claims
that there are each and that is
something for the courts and in terms of
let me just just answer two because at
the moment we have a situation back in
the early years of this government in
March 2011 the Asylum backlog was
probably just under about six thousand
it's now 138
000. should we be processing those
claims far more quickly so that we can
see those that have a genuine claim
who've always had a safe haven here and
those who do not have a valid claim that
need to be returned to Safe countries
absolutely we should be that's what I've
been trying to vote for in the House of
Commons that's where the government's
been failing um Andrew Mitchell said
that the legislation today is in his
words pushing the limits of
international law is it breaking
international law well the Home
Secretary in placing a certificate the
so-called section 19 certificate uh
under the human rights act on the bill
wasn't able to give a full assurance
that he followed International and that
is he and let me just say that that is a
profound error from this government
because I aspire to negotiate trade
deals around the world and that is
important for our prosperity and to do
that we have to be a country whose word
is believed that when we sign on the
dotted line for our International
obligations we are a country that is
going to stand by that in the years
ahead and this breaking uh International
we've heard it before of course when uh
the then Northern Ireland secretary
talks about breaking international law
in a limited and specific way that
damages us standing on the international
stage and ultimately will damage our
prosperity as well so just finally if
labor was in power would you overturn
this legislation
we will pass legislation that gives
effect to the principles that I set out
in the interview a moment or two ago
Sophie so that we can actually have a an
immigration system that is fair that's
what we will do okay thank you thank you